Logan Paul Logan Logan Logan and you
know it's unfortunate all this is going
down because I really I do think he's a
hard worker and I think it's unfortunate
to watch a guy build an entire career
just to be embarrassed by a chick I
think I I feel really bad for the guys
like this so you know Logan Paul again
he's fighting Dylan danis and Dylan
danis all week has been tweeting picture
after picture after picture of of
Logan's fiance with other chicks now I'm
gonna I'm gonna be fair some of it is
just taking pictures with guys but but I
think we're at over 75 pictures she was
a model so there's a lot of nude shoots
there's a lot of risque photos so let's
let's
um and Logan has finally responded to
Dylan danis so let's let's pull the clip
I know who Nina is she knows who I am
we've been so transparent about each
other's past she's a angel she's
had long-term boyfriends her whole life
uh every guy in the world wants to date
her only a few could and say they got to
I'm the one that was lucky enough to
lock her down and it's so stupid that I
have to come on here and like clarify
the fact that my supermodel girlfriend
he's had an amazing career and has built
an amazing life for herself got
Paparazzi with her exes like yeah she
took pictures with her exes yes guys
came up to her I wanted to take photos
including LeBron who came up to
her and wanted a photo yes she's done
professional modeling shoots and said
provocative because it gets clicks
like she's in the industry she's in
Hollywood and again it's so stupid I
have to clarify this but like me and
Nina are good we love the
out of each other she's my fiance I
cannot wait to marry her and Dylan just
takes it below the belt and bro at one
point I was the most hated person on the
planet right I don't give a what
anyone says you know you're not me you
don't know my life you don't know Nina
you don't know me so shut the up
live your life you can comment on mine
but at the end of the day I don't give a
thank you for saying I can comment on
yours because that's what I'm gonna do
I'm here I'm ready okay
um all right so I actually didn't think
this was the worst response in the world
I actually thought it was it was decent
right
um I I a couple things you can kind of
tell when a guy has a more like blue
pilled mentality a bit more naive and
that's why a lot of times guys will say
in the manosphere that you can have
money but it doesn't mean you understand
women and you can get women but it
doesn't mean that you under understand
them because really
um in my opinion she's just running like
game a bit on him
um do you really think LeBron James
wanted a picture
with this model that nobody heard of
until she started dating you
that does that doesn't really make sense
to me that you know
um
and this idea like he he's almost
um judging her on masculine standards so
she's saying she built this amazing life
for herself she had this amazing career
and this is what guys have been told to
judge women on and to act like
brainwashing doesn't work on that is
definitely false like you see men
emoting like women speaking like women
because you know they go into they're
raised by a lot of times either single
mothers or really domineering mothers I
don't know much about their home life
but if I had to guess it's probably a
more domineering mother that doesn't let
the the husband lead right
um
uh he doesn't give me the single mother
home like I think it was probably a
domineering mom but yeah and you see him
judging his fiancee on masculine
standards a career
um long-term ex-boyfriends but I was the
lucky enough one to lock her down well
maybe there's a reason they didn't lock
her down you know typically I mean
typically Superstars you know when a
woman's a unicorn
men will lock her lock them down you
know what I mean or it also shows a lack
of ability to commit now she actually
seems very nice so I I'm not even trying
to go too in on her but my point is this
there's a lot of red flags coming in and
I do think this is gonna red pill a lot
of guys that you know just because she
waits to sleep with you it doesn't mean
she's innocent she could just be
sleeping with her ex-boyfriend or
someone else and you know that's why you
have the fresh and fit guys that say
sleep with 50 women before you commit
because otherwise you kind of get
bamboozled like this that's why the
Freshman got fit guys would say well
most women are so treat them like
such so you know if she doesn't sleep
with you on the first date She's Not
That Into You because there's probably
someone else that's it and
you know I don't
I don't say that to be all women but you
know on a balance of probabilities is
probably in present day it's probably
more that do that than don't
Logan Paul I I really wish them the best
but it'll be I think he's gonna marry
her I totally thought he was gonna drop
her after all this stuff came out but
yeah it looks like he's gonna marry her